اهلا بكم قالت وزاره الداخليه البحريني ما
بثته قناه تمولها ايران عن هجوم استهدف
الاحد سجن جنوب شرق البحرين يمثل دعما
ايرانيا للاعمال الارهابيه واشارت الوزاره
في تغريده على حسابها الرسمي في موقع
تويتر الى ان قناه اهل البيت التي تبث من
مدينه كربلاء العراقيه قالت ان العمليه
على سجن جو تمت بنجاح وهو ما اعتبرته
الوزاره ارتباطا مباشرا لايران بالاعمال
الارهابيه واصرار على التدخل في شؤون
البحرين العمليه على سجن جو تمت بنجاح
تعليق لقناه تلفزيونيه تمولها ايران بعد
حادثه الاعداء المسلح على سجن في البحرين
قتل فيه شرطي واصيب اخر اضافه الى تهريب
سجناء مدانين بالارهاب كانت بن الهجوم
ومباركته مؤشرا بنت عليه المنامه اتهاما
لايران بالضلوع في العمليه وزاره الداخليه
البحرينيه في بيان على تويتر اعتبرت ذلك
دعما ايرانيا وارتباطا مباشرا قناه ال
البيت التي تبث من كرب ئ في العراق لم
تنفي الاتهام ودابت ك نظيراتها من وسائل
الاعلام المرتبطه بايران في كل من العراق
ولبناني وسوريا على انتهاج اسلوب التحريض
وتجيش الخطاب الطائفي ضد دول عربيه بينها
بلدان الخليج فضلا عن التباهي علانيه ببث
عمليات اجراميه اودت بحياه ابرياء كانت
حادثه تهريب محكوم عليهم شيعه من سجن جوء
الواقع جنوب شرقي المنامه مناسبه اخرى
لتلك القنوات و مؤيديها لمباركه العمليه
لم يعرف بعد مصير الفارين العشره من السجن
وهم سبعه محكوم عليهم بالمؤبد وثلاثه صدرت
عليهم احكام بالسجن فترات متفاوته بتهم
القيام باعمال ارهابيه قادت العمليه حسب
وزاره الداخليه البحرينيه مجموعه مكونه من
خمسه افراد استخدموا بنادق اوتوماتيكيه
رشاشه وقد وقع حادث نادر مماثل في البحرين
في احد السجون قبل عامين لكن السلطات
تمكنت سريعا من قبض على معظم الفارين
انذاك اتهام البحرين الجديد لايران
بالتورط في اضطرابات امنيه فيها ليس الاول
من نوعه فقد سبق ان اتهمتها بدعم اعمال
عنف واخرى تحريضيه عدا عن محاولات تهريب
السلاح للداخل عبر جماعات ارهابيه برا
وبحرا التفجير الذي وقع في منطقه سترا
وخلف قتل وجرحى من رجال الشرطه عام
2015 قالت المنامه ان المتورطين مرتبطين
بايران كما القت القبض على عده عناصر
مسلحه وخلايا و بحوزتها اسلحه ومواد
متفجره ايرانيه الصنع واحتجزت سفنا تقوم
بتهريب السلاح علاقه البلدين تكتنفها
خصومات تاريخيه وسياسيه مستمره رغم هدوئها
في مراحل معينه الا ان الخلافات سرعان ما
تعود الى الواجهه من جديد بعد حوادث تقول
البحرين انها تخل بامن واستقرار مجتمعها
وتثير الطائفيه المستورده ممارسه ايران
والموالين لها تثير حفظه دول عربيه عده
وتدفعها لاتهام ايران بنشر الفوضى والتطرف
وتاجي الخطاب الطائفي فضلا عن اتهامها
بالقيام باعمال امنيه وعسكريه تسببت في
ازهاق كثير من ارواح المدنيين لا سما في
سوريا والعراق واليمن التي تجاهر ايران
بالتدخل فيها وعلى
الملاء لمناقشه هذا الموضوع انضم الينا من
بغداد المحلل السياسي مناف الموسوي ومن
الكويت عضو البرلمان العربي ورئيس لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس الامه الكويتي
علي الدقباسي
سيد الدقباسي ما مدى صلبه الحجه التي بنت
عليها السلطات البحرينيه اتهامها لايران
بالضلوع في هذه العمليه ونعني بذلك احتفاء
قناه
تلفزيونيه عراقيه بما سمته نجاح
العمليه اعتقد ببساطه لسنا بحاجه الى
البيان من مملكه البحر
ولا من قناه فضائيه مموله من ايران ان
تقول بان هناك تعدي على الامن القومي
العربي لان هذا مسلسل يتخذ اشكال مختلفه
في اوقات مختلفه الكل يعرف المشهد في
العالم العربي ومدى اختراق الامن القومي
العربي ومدى الاعمال العدائيه والارهابيه
التي تمولها ايران
بشكل ظاهر وواضح للاعيان وفي اقطار عده من
العالم العربي ب بدا من لبنان ومرورا في
سوريا والعراق واليمن وحتى في الكويت هنا
تم اكتشاف مخازن اسلحه وشبكات تجسس وما
يجري في البحرين هذا يعني مسلسل من حلقه
طويله ناهيك عن ما يحصل ايضا حتى في اليمن
وهذا امر ما هو محتاج الى اني اسمع من احد
يقول لي عليه هناك اختراق للامن القومي
العربي وهناك اعمال عدائيه مستمره وهناك
اصرار من الجانب الايراني على تمويل
الجماعات الارهابيه و محاوله بث الفرقه
والطائفيه في المجتمعات العربيه كمدخل
لتفتيت هذه المجتمعات وضرب وحدتها الوطنيه
هذا ليس بحاجه الى اني اسمع من احد انا
اشاهد وكما يقول طه حسين تحدث لكي اراك
نحن نرى ونسمع الحديث الايراني المستمر عن
الاصرار في التدخل في امن القوم العربي بل
الاعمال الادائيه المتكرره وانا احذر من
خلال هذا المنبر من من الوقوف صامتين امام
استمرار هذه الاعمال العدائيه
المتكرره سنعود الى
هذا الى هذا الى هذه العناوين الفرعيه صحت
السيد الموسوي ما مدى توافقك مع هذا الراي
يعني هل هل يبدو منطقيا هو السيد الدقباسي
يقول ان المساله لا تحتاج في في المطلق
الى اي يعني حجج والى اي تدليل ولكن
بالنسبه لما بثته هذه القنا التلفزيونيه
هل يبدو فعلا منطقيا انها كانت تغرد خارج
السرب وهي المعروف عنها انها مموله من
ايران
متماهياً يعني انا اود ان اتحدث اولا يعني
نحتاج ان نبين او ان نبرهن ان هذه القناه
تمول من ايران حتى لا ادخل في هذا في هذا
الموضوع مع العلم انا ابدي تحفظي لاي
استخدام غير الاستخدام السلمي في المطالبه
الشعبويه هذا هذا اولا المساله الثانيه
لماذا لا ناخذ الموضوع من جانب اخر يعني
لماذا لا تمول هذه القناه من قبل المعارضه
البحرينيه التي يعني ابتدات مطالبات يعني
لم تكن مطالبات كبيره او غير منطقيه او
غير واقعيه المطالبه بالمساواه المطالبه
بحقوق المواطنه المطالبه بالعيش الامن في
البلد لم تكن لم تكن مطالبات حقيقيه
وبالتالي منجي قوات خارجيه تتحدث عن امن
الوطن العربي لضرب ابناء هذا هذا الوطن
تقد هذه الاسباب المساله ليست
متعلقه الكلام الكلام كله ليس متعلق بهذه
الحادث
تحديدا ولكن انت تعلم ان العلاقات
البحرينيه الايرانيه يعني مرت وتمر
بتوترات وازمات عديده وكانت هناك دائما
اتهامات بحرينيه لايران
ب
جودها القائمه على التجييش الطائفي ليس
فقط في المملكه ولكن في في المنطقه
الخليجيه كلها يعني هذا قديم ليس
جديد يعني سيدي هذا الموضوع ايضا يدخل في
في في باب الصراع السياسي او عمليه رمي
الكره او او تبادل الاتهامات للخروج من
المساله الرئيسيه وهو ان هنالك معارضين
مواطنين بحرينيين معارضين يسجنون بطريقه
لمحاوله استخدامهم التعبير عن الراي
بطريقه ربما قد لا تصل الى الى هذا
الاتجاه وبالتالي يعني انا اتساءل هل يعني
نقول ان عمليه دعم المعارضين السوريين
تعتبر عمليه تدخل عرب في الشان السوري
وانا يعني اخشى من هذه المشكله اخشى من ان
البعض حينما يحاول ان يدافع عن الاخطاء
التي تمارس من قبل الحكومات في ظل هذه
الفتره هي ان ان تعيد لنا مسلسل سوريا
وبالتالي يعني الخساره كبيره للجميع لان
كل ما يقتل هو هو عربي وكل ما يقتل
وبالنتيجه ان نتخلص من هذا الموضوع هذه
العمليه بالذات هذه العمليه وما سبقها
يعني دائما ثير الهواجس الخليجيه بشكل عام
ف دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي اعربت عن
ادانتها شديده للهجوم المسلح على مركز
الاصلاح والتاهيل في مدينه جو بمملكه
البحرين وقالها الامين العام لمجلس
التعاون عبد اللطيف الزياني ان دول المجلس
تدين بشده هذا الهجوم المسلح باعتباره
عملا ارهابيا شنيعا كما تؤكد دعمها
ومساندتها لمملكه البحرين في كل ما تتخذه
من اجراءات لحمايه امنها والحفاظ على
سلامه مواطنيها والمقيمين على اراضيها
واعرب الزياني عن ثقته في قدره اجهزه
الامن البحرينيه على سرعه القبض على
المتورطين في العمليه وكشف الجهات المحرضه
والمسانده لها سيد الدقباسي ما مدى
مسؤوليه الدول الخليجيه ومجلس التعاون
الخليجي في التعامل مع هذه الممارسات
الايرانيه وضع حد
لها
في البدايه انا اتفهم قيض الضيف الاخر في
هذه الحلقه
واتساءل لماذا لا يرد على اسئلتك تساله في
قضيه ويجيب في قضيه اخرى هو يحاول ان يخلق
معركه جانبيه بيني وبينه لكي نبعد عن
الحديث انا هذه الالاعيب الاعلاميه يعني
لا تنطلي علي وانا اقول بان ما يجري ليس
لا يمت
لمساله حق الشعوب في الحر ريه والكرامه
والاصلاحات ما يجري هو حاله حرب نحن في
العالم العربي نعيش حاله حرب حقيقيه وردا
على سؤالك ان المنظومه الخليجيه هي من
تتحمل العب الان في الدفاع عن الامن
القومي العربي لان مؤسسات العمل العربي
التقليديه العمل العربي المشترك في حاله
غيبوبه والكل يعرف انت تعرف وانا اعرف
والمشاهدين يعرفون بان المشهد في العرا
العراق كيف هو تدخل ايران يسافر فيه وكذلك
في سوريا وكذلك في اليمن وكذلك في لبنان
وهم يريدون ان يشهدوا الخليج ان يكون بهذه
الحاله دعني اوصل لك فكره بسيطه انا اعتقد
انه ليس هناك انصاف حلول نحن في حاله حرب
ايران في ظل صمت عالمي مريب ويثير علامات
استفهام وتعجب قاعده تنتشر
بشكل تحت ظل وسمع ونظر القانون الدولي
ومسا الدوليه وتنقل سلاح وتعمل شبكه
جواسيس ومتفجرات وارهاب علنا هذا واضح
تماما ل الاعيان وانا اقول انا اثق في موض
تعاون خليجي واثق في قياداتنا اشكرك اشكرك
سيد علي الدقباسي اذا رئيس البرلمان
العربي السابق وعضو مجلس الامه الكويتي
واشكر من بغداد الكاتب الصحفي منف الموسوي
في وقفتنا الاخيره ينقلنا عبد الصمد ناصر
الى اجواء السودان واصلاحاته الدستوريه
ومشهده السياسي وال ma